en españa residen aproximadamente 122
mil franceses y de los que estaban
habilitados para votar lo pudieron hacer
en unos 18 centros habilitados en toda
la península ibérica y en los dos
archipiélagos españoles tanto en las
islas baleares como en las islas
canarias mientras que en francia ya no
era obligatorio el uso de mascarillas en
interiores si tenían que llevarlo puesto
en los votantes que lo hicieron en
españa puesto que aquí siguen esas
restricciones por la pandemia de kobe 19
mientras que la abstención ha sido una
de las protagonistas en esta primera
vuelta de 2022 también lo fue en 2017
entre los votantes que residían en
españa y que fueron a votar en los
diferentes consulados y centros
habilitados de los 71 mil inscritos para
votar tan sólo lo hicieron 27.000 es
decir la abstención fue del 62 por
ciento en la primera vuelta una
abstención que se mantuvo alta el 60% en
segunda vuelta pero de esos 60 por
ciento del 88% de esos votos se fue a
emanuel macrón que también se veían las
caras contra la que parece ser que va a
ser la contrincante en segunda vuelta
también
sin gluten porque son importantes los
resultados de estas elecciones para
españa pues porque francia es el primer
cliente comercial de españa y supone en
la cuota de más o menos 20% de las
exportaciones que hace españa y francia
es el segundo proveedor de españa así
que dependiendo de si el presidente o la
presidenta de francia es más europeísta
o no eso se podría haber afectado
también porque francia y españa-
colaboran mucho en temas como por
ejemplo la lucha contra el terrorismo y
por supuesto el turismo que supone más
del 10 por ciento del producto interno
bruto de españa pues los franceses son
la nacionalidad número uno en cuanto a
visitas extranjeras al país el año
pasado en 2021 5,8 millones de franceses
visitaron españa lo que supuso casi el
20 por ciento de los extranjeros que
llegaron al país